[Musica]
deserto è difficile da definire perché
sicuramente per me non è un luogo forse
un non luogo la dimostrazione il fatto
che si può essere in un deserto anche in
una sala gremita di persone si può
essere il deserto anche nel centro di
new york
quindi non è un luogo per la mia della
mia visione il deserto è un'esperienza
con tre esperienze dipende
esclusivamente da come lo si vive in
negativo in positivo io preferisco
vivere tutte in positivo allora stasera
vorrei accompagnarvi in un altro viaggio
un viaggio attraverso i miei deserto
viaggio che parte dal basso verso l'alto
in un continuo e cominciamo subito qui
siamo molto in basso nelle nelle caverne
sotto la sardegna
a volte i deserti sono invisibili noi
siamo abituati a vederli all'esterno
piatti o con delle montagne ma a volte i
deserti sono interiori e non soltanto in
senso in senso morale deserto come può
avere dentro ma anche nel senso proprio
fisico qui siamo in un deserto
dentro una montagna svariati metri sotto
le montagne in particolare in questo
momento in questa foto sono in un
budello che mi schiaccia completamente
sotto decine e decine di metri di terra
e rocce e tonnellate di roccia mentre
ero in questo budello ho pensato di
spegnere la luce che avevo sul casco ero
completamente solo dentro questo budello
che volevo sentire volevo sentire il
deserto di questa montagna che mi
schiacciava completamente ed ero
bloccato l'unico modo per spostarmi in
quel buio allora in avanti spingendo
molto lentamente con
con i piedi e con le mani perché volevo
provare la sensazione di essere
completamente solo poi riacceso la luce
ho rivisto i miei colleghi sono sbucato
dall'altro lato quasi come fosse un
premio c'era un fiume sotterraneo
meraviglioso quindi un deserto
invisibile sempre al buio trasformato da
migliaia di anni di lavoro sotterraneo
dell'acqua in questa foto vediamo lo
stesso deserto sempre sempre sotto le
montagne della sardegna ma come vedete è
cambiato completamente completamente
l'opposto siamo passati da un budello
strettissimo a un deserto enorme ma
dalle dimensioni
guardate quest'uomo che sta indicando
qui questo è un uomo questa è una parete
di circa 80 metri di altezza all'interno
di una montagna
quindi un mondo completamente
sconosciuto di roccia che racconta una
storia questa è la storia di una
pazienza infinita di movimenti
impercettibili ma ineluttabili di acqua
che goccia dopo goccia trasforma la
roccia fino a dominarla perché quella
parete è completamente crollata creando
questo deserto di pietre dove io sono
con il mio equipaggio l'equipaggio della
spedizione games del 2014
sottoterra con un gruppo di astronauti e
gli scienziati perché perché andiamo
sotto terra perché mandiamo gli
astronauti sottoterra bene deserto non
vuol dire mancanza di vita non vuol dire
assenza di vita vuol dire tante cose ma
non necessariamente quello infatti noi
pensiamo che su marte ci siano delle
grotte molto molto grandi che proteggono
l'habitat sotterraneo
le radiazioni quindi pensiamo che sia un
ottimo ambiente per custodire ancora
natura organica
forse la vita o comunque i resti di
quella vita potrebbe essere uno dei
primi luoghi che visiteremo quando
andremo su marte perché saremo protetti
protetti dalle radiazioni in questo
deserto alle mie spalle
vedete un astronauta che si accinge a
calarsi all'interno di una grotta
utilizzando gli stessi strumenti che poi
un giorno gli astronauti del futuro
dovranno utilizzare per esplorare le
farà esplorazione nelle caverne marziane
o magari in un tubo lavico lunare
sappiamo che ci sono sappiamo che
esistono ma questo non è soltanto
addestramento per astronauti e anche
scienza sapere che nei deserti e come in
tutti gli ambienti estremi esistono
procedure l'evoluzione in atto è
perfettamente visibili in particolare il
deserti sotterranei sono completamente
privi di luce
se noi spegnessimo quella luce sarebbe
assolutamente buio un buio diverso da
quello che ho provato nello spazio un
buio più denso e carico di quelle
tonnellate di terra sopra di noi
bene questi animaletti minuscoli hanno
abbandonato l'evoluzione normale dei
loro simili sopra la superficie per
adattarsi a quelle condizioni così
estreme pochissima energia
niente luce ecco che questi animali
diventano quasi trasparenti perché anche
il colore anche generare del colore e
uno sforzo inutile e abbandonato gli
occhi sono animali senza occhi non hanno
non hanno più quest'organo ne hanno
sviluppati altri che sono più utili
sotto terra per sentire le vibrazioni
per sentire a temperatura le variazioni
minuscole e poter trovare il modo di
sostentare dalla propria vita ecco che
noi andiamo a cercare sotto terra
con degli scienziati e impariamo anche
come fare il campionamento come
raccoglierli in modo che un giorno
saremo in grado di farlo anche su un
altro pianeta
un gruppo molto famoso degli anni 70 che
mi piace moltissimo in una canzone ha
scritto l'oceano è un deserto con la sua
vita sotterranea costruita sommersa è il
perfetto travestimento sopra e io l'ho
visto qui siamo a circa 20 metri sotto
il mare al largo della costa della
florida durante una spedizione che si
chiama nimo nasa extreme environment
mission operations la foto alle
caratteristiche una foto su bach quindi
non ha i colori brillanti però potete
vedere il deserto intorno a me è un vero
deserto
anche se è pieno di vita ma il deserto
con tutte le stesse difficoltà di un
ambiente estremo
abbiamo vissuto per circa due settimane
completamente in saturazione quindi non
potevamo risalire in caso di emergenza a
meno di avere un supporto speciale tutte
le nostre tutto il necessario era con
noi dobbiamo portare appresso
ebbene sott'acqua abbiamo fatto la
stessa sperimentazione che faremmo sun
su un altro corpo su un altro corpo
celeste ad esempio lavorare in
microgravità perché sott'acqua è
possibile cambiare il proprio assetto
per far finta per simulare di essere
completamente senza peso o con un peso
marziale senza penso come se fossimo su
un asteroide su deimos su phobos intorno
a marte oppure gravità parziale come
sulla luna o su marte bene per imparare
a muoversi in questi ambienti così
diversi dal nostro
utilizziamo l'ambiente sottomarino per
comprendere anche che strumenti dobbiamo
sviluppare e creare sperimentare prima
di poterli utilizzare su marte
ecco perché in questo finto lander che
vedrete alle mie spalle abbiamo
agganciato un braccio robotico
sul quale spostarci per non contaminare
solo lunare e marziano così via
ma non facciamo solo sperimentazione
anche qui facciamo scienza vedete
insieme alla florida international
university
abbiamo studiato un fenomeno pochissimo
conosciuto la migrazione dei coralli i
coralli sono molto molto sensibili alla
temperatura
abbiamo studiato in che modo si spostano
verso acque più profonde a causa del
riscaldamento globale
qui il riscaldamento globale è un fatto
e scienza non è più un argomento
politico non è più una discussione
politica e per fare in modo che questo
deserto vivente non diventi una valle
della morte dobbiamo fare qualcosa
adesso noi ci stiamo provando con la
scienza
torniamo in superficie
siamo partiti da sottoterra andiamo più
in alto passando per il mare torniamo in
superficie e qui siamo a lanzarote per
un altro progetto di esplorazione che si
chiama pang ea come il il macro
continente che poi dato origine a tutti
i continenti
qui siamo su su un cratere di cui
possiamo raccontare la storia solo se
conosciamo il linguaggio della terra
i geologi parlano il linguaggio delle
rocce sono in grado di ascoltarne la
storia di sentirne il raccolto sono in
grado di interpretarlo per noi
io non sono un geologo non posso
interpretare le conformazioni del
terreno quando quando quando mi guardo
intorno
ma utilizzando le loro informazioni in
loro loro istruzione posso descrivere
come se fossero i loro occhi aveva
osservarlo in modo che loro possano
invece a raccontare quella storia e
farne scienza
perché comprendere come si evolve un
terreno in milioni e milioni di anni e
re rispetto alla alla vita umana anno
nelle tempistiche incomprensibili
comprendere in che modo il terreno si è
voluto ci permette anche di capire come
si evolverà in futuro e di comprendere
la storia dell'universo
io mi chiedo per trovare un posto sulla
terra che assomiglia a marte ti
piacerebbe poter essere quello sono io
in quel momento pensavo proprio potrei
essere su marte ma non lo sono sono
sulla terra
e chissà che storia raccontano questi
sassi rossi questo questa valle
completamente diversa da qualsiasi altro
ambiente un ambiente che potrebbe essere
su marte abbiamo provato con con i
nostri istruttori i geologi
professionisti esploratori a cercare di
raccontare questa storia è una storia
veramente complessa sarebbe bello un
giorno poter poterla raccontare
andiamo ancora più in alto
questo è il deserto più estremo per
eccellenza e dell'unico deserto a essere
veramente vuoto lo so che è vuoto perché
visto per uscire dalla stazione spaziale
internazionale una camera stagna abbiamo
depressurizzato completamente e lo
scampanellio disordinato degli strumenti
che ho davanti a un certo punto è
scomparso è diventato silenzioso non
c'era più sono quindi sono anche se sono
dentro la stazione sono già nel deserto
e il deserto del vuoto del vuoto dello
spazio
ho provato due sensazioni che sono
tipiche del deserto sapere nei deserti
per chi ha avuto l'esperienza di poterli
vivere gli spettacoli della natura sono
di una bellezza rara diversa
vedere le stelle da un deserto ha
un'intensità superiore un tramonto
un'alba bene ho visto un alba dallo
spazio mentre ho agganciato abbraccio
spaziale al braccio robotico e l'alba
l'albero allo spazio e con un'esperienza
diversa è un'esperienza estremamente
rapida in pochissimi istanti dal dal
mero che vi assorbe completamente che vi
toglie qualsiasi sensazioni di colore da
questo nero che vi assorbe anche nel
pensiero
si passa all esplosione di colori in un
attimo
io volevo sopra l'oceano atlantico a un
certo punto il blu dell'oceano si è
trasformato in azzurro poi nel bianco
delle onde poi nella terracotta della
costa africana nel verde e poi il blu
del cielo tutto in un attimo ho la
sensazione che toglie il fiato
e mentre è così come il tramonto è
estremamente tragico del deserto
anch'io ho sperimentato un tramonto
diverso da tutti gli altri sperimentato
un tramonto mentre ero isolato fuori
dalla stazione in emergenza quando il
mio caso ho cominciato a riempirsi
d'acqua per ricordarmi che la natura ha
sempre il modo di prendere il
sopravvento sul singolo individuo e li
nell'ambiente più estremo che esiste al
mondo è fuori dal mondo senza atmosfera
senza aria con temperature che vanno da
meno 150 gradi e più 150 gradi
il mio scafandro che l'unico strumento
tecnologico che mi tiene in vita è
andato in avaria riempiendomi il casco
di acqua è un tipo di deserto diverso
che siano approvare e quando è
tramontato il sole
ho perso anche l'unico strumento che con
facilità mi avrebbe riportato a casa gli
occhi
infine questa foto che adesso vede le
mie spalle
questa foto è dedicata a chi in sala e
più di koman e alla prossima generazione
è un invito ma anche una sfida in questa
foto la cosa più bella che si riesce a
vedere è riflesso della terra è la mia
sfida è di migliorare questa foto di
superarla perché l'uomo a un gene che
quello dell'esplorazione è un vero e
proprio genere il gene di ulisse quando
noi serviamo un orizzonte abbiamo
l'istinto di superarlo non possiamo fare
a meno di chiederci cosa c'è al di là di
quell orizzonte
allora io oggi lavoro per permettere ai
più giovani di superare quell'orizzonte
è la mia sfida è di fare questa foto nel
futuro un giorno con un deserto alle
spalle mi piacerebbe vedere questo
pianeta diventare tutto rosso della
sabbia di marte
grazie all'attenzione buonasera
[Musica]